Dude,
favorite conversation among film Geeks
is which Wes Anderson movie is the best.
I love this conversation because there's
so much to love about all of them and
you can't really argue with somebody who
picks rushmore or the royal tannenbaums
where the Grand Budapest hotel,
so really the conversation is less about
competition and more about how one
particular movie in this director,
his filmography affected someone
personally.
How one particular angle of Anderson's
vision hit that person squarely in the
face because of where or when or who
they were at that moment in their lives.
For me,
that film is the Darjeeling limited the
story about three brothers on a
spiritual journey through India.
The brother who brings them together.
Francis says the journey is about trust,
but it's really about communication.
How after a year of not speaking and the
lifetime of upper middle class anxiety,
their ability to talk with each other
coherently has completely broken down.
The first conversation they have on the
train tells you everything you need to
know.
It plays like some hilarious group chat
where one or all three of the brothers
has terrible
well cell service and struggles to keep
up the last two.
You want to read a short story I wrote
in France.
I think everybody knows that close
friends and especially family don't
always answer the questions that you ask
them,
the answer,
the question that they think your
question implies.
They try to anticipate where you're
going at its best.
This makes for a wonderful shorthand,
but at it's worst,
assumptions like these can be incredibly
frustrating and make for stilted
communication that never hits its mark
with everyone zigzagging and working at
cross purposes in the Darjeeling Limited
Jack Francis and Peter's spend a lot of
time communicating to themselves through
juggling.
Raise us.
Francis is especially guilty of this.
He organizes this bogus spiritual
journey to process his father's death.
Now a year past,
he thinks maybe that if he can't connect
his brothers through discovering some
deep profundity in India,
that the tragedy will be senseless.
After all,
we're told that pain makes us stronger,
that it has lessons to teach.
What if it doesn't?
He's so desperate for connection that he
spends the entire movie literalized in
it,
in the form of an agreement,
make an agreement.
Let's make another agreement.
Let's make another agree.
We agreed to that and you agree to that.
We read to that can we agree to agree to
that?
Jack and Peter Process the grief in
their own ways.
Jack writes a short story about the
funeral and he's also grieving by the
way,
the end of a romantic relationship,
something that's detailed in a really
great short film that Precedes
Darjeeling called Hotel Shivali aid with
Natalie Portman.
The brothers seemed to think that his
solution to everything is to run away
from keeping his passport,
but it's that little gift from his ex
shows.
Grief is like a scent.
It lingers and has a deep link with
memory runaway and it'll follow you.
Try to destroy it and you'll only
unleash the aroma in a more potent form.
Jesus,
Peter,
I think who takes the tragedy hardest.
Not only is he the angriest of the
three,
but his entire life has become
distorted.
His caring wife is weeks away from
having their first child and he's in
India.
He appropriates his father's belongings,
namely his prescription sunglasses which
make the world unfocused in the world.
Tenenbaums.
Richie hides behind giant sunglasses so
that the world can't see him in
darjeeling.
Jack wears prescription sunglasses so
that he can't see the world.
I think that communication has been at
the heart of West Anderson style from
the start.
It might be that he has similar
anxieties to Francis and need to ensure
that a message given has been received.
This is one way to read all his 90 and
180 degree quick pants in the same way
that Francis asks for an agreement for
everything.
Anderson takes the coolest chava effect
where viewers derive meaning from the
relationship between two shots perfected
I hitchcock and fills in all the missing
information showing how those two or
three or four compositions are
connected.
Of course,
West Anderson loves to match personal
crises with visual motifs,
and he doesn't shy away from obvious
ones either like brothers,
unwilling to feel real trauma,
all having some form of painkiller
symbols of failed communication can come
in the form of a dropped bag.
A command shouted that no one in
particular,
a soft whisper before sex,
a sense of moving forward,
but not getting anywhere.
It can be a train that gets lost,
lost sunrail.
Jack's tendency to turn his life into
the perfect fiction can be made physical
in the form of an ipod.
Speaker in this too is likely a
personality trait that Anderson shares.
I mean,
how is this any different from this?
I don't necessarily think the darjeeling
limited is the formal peak of Anderson's
work,
but I think that it's the most human of
his films.
Since the ensemble is limited mostly to
three people,
we get a deeper dive into each
personality and much more importantly
into the web that makes them,
in many ways a single organism.
One of my favorite things about the film
and not so obvious visual flourish is
the design of the train compartment,
namely these two equally sized panels on
both sides of the interior wall.
One is a mirror and the other is an
internal window,
but of course it's hard to tell those
two things apart.
Francis,
Jack and Peter are constantly throwing
barbs at one another,
feeling out the contours of own
identities.
Sometimes they hit the target.
Other times it's reflected back.
Mostly.
It's both.
I guess that's the point about
communication.
You can't help speaking to yourself when
you speak to others.
Others can't help hearing something
about themselves even when they know
that you're projecting onto them.
Strange.
The Darjeeling limited is my favorite
wes Anderson movie.
It came out when I was just starting
college trying to find my identity in
others and it hit me square in the face
and yeah,
I do think it's the best for now,
but that's not definitive.
It's just the opening salvo in a
conversation between me and everybody
who watches this channel.
A bunch of film Geeks,
so what do you think?
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I had been waiting for ever to do a
video on West Anderson.
This was so much fun and me and my
friends really do have these
conversations all the time about which
we think is the best and I love all.
I love moonrise kingdom and I love life
aquatic and,
and they're also good.
But uh,
you know,
everybody's got their favorite for one
reason or another.
This is mine.
What's yours?
Let me know in the comments and if you
want to subscribe to this channel,
you can click right over here and if you
want to pledge a dollar or $3 helps the
most per video.
Thank you so much for watching.
I'll see you all next Wednesday.